la population mondiale continue de
croître l'onu estime que le 15 novembre
prochain la planète comptera 8 milliards
d'habitants ces données s'expliquent
entre autres par l'augmentation du
nombre d'individus en âge de procréer
les progrès en santé ont aussi contribué
à augmenter l'espérance de vie et à
réduire la mortalité maternelle et
infantile
surtout et e le secrétaire général des
nations unies écrit entre autres
veillons à ce que notre monde puisse
répondre à nos besoins et à ceux des
générations futures
les changements climatiques les
violences et les discriminations
demeurent des enjeux qui marque les
inégalités partout sur la planète en mai
dernier on comptait plus de 100 millions
de déplacés de force dans le monde alors
que la chine trônait au sommet du
palmarès des pays les plus peuplés les
données démontrent qu'elle se fera
dépasser par l'inde en 2023 où la
population célèbre à 1 milliard 400
millions de personnes au cours des
années à venir
plus de la moitié de la croissance
mondiale de la population sera en
république démocratique du congo en
egypte en ethiopie en inde ou nigeria au
pakistan aux philippines et en tanzanie
pendant que dans les pays considérés
comme étant développé la fécondité est
en chute libre
quoi qu'il en soit la croissance se
poursuit le nombre d'humains sur terre
devrait atteindre 9 milliards 700
millions en 2050 ici valérie michaela
bayne radio-canada à montréal